-Our next guest is a legendary
Emmy-winning television writer
and producer behind shows
like "All in the Family,"
"The Jeffersons,"
and "Sanford and Son."
His book, "All in the Family:
The Show That Changed
Television,"
is out November 2nd.
Please welcome to the show
Norman Lear, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There he is!
-Norman,
I'm so happy to see you.
You are 99, which means
you're in your 100th year,
and I'm assuming you get
asked this all the time.
You're probably exhausted
answering it.
But how do you do it, Norman?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, I wake up every morning.
-That sounds --
That seems like that's probably
the key to the whole thing.
-I always think about
two little words
we don't pay
enough attention to.
"Over" and "next."
When something is over,
it's over,
and we are all on to next.
And if there was a hammock
in the middle,
that would be
the best definition
I could give
of living in the moment.
So I think that's what
I have been able to do.
The fact that my life is --
It's taken me
every split second of my life
to finish this sentence.
[ Laughter ]
And it just took you every split
second of your life to go...
[ Imitates laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
So it's an important moment.
-It was lovely
to read about this show.
It must be nice going back and
revisiting it in your memory.
I want to ask -- You know, now,
I think, people would not
even begin to think that
the show would not have worked,
but, you know, no show
is guaranteed success.
When did you know
it was working?
-Are you talking about --
-"All in the Family."
Uh...
You know,
I made it three year--
I made it three times
before it went on the air.
Made it in New York twice
and once here
before it went on the air.
Always with Carroll O'Connor
and Jean Stapleton,
but the first two times
absent
the Rob Reiner
and Sally Struthers.
We made it
with two other young people.
And it was a blessing that
the network didn't pick it up
because by the time it came --
by the time
we found Rob and Sally,
the chemistry
between each of those four
in every direction
was so glorious and so --
That was, you know,
the fate of the gods.
-It was not universally loved
by critics
when it first came out.
You would respond to the critics
when this happened.
Do you remember
any of that back-and-forth
or do you remember
why people didn't like it
right out of the gate?
-Uh, well, they didn't like --
You know, didn't understand
the reason for a bigot...
as the center of a show.
And there was a review
by the name of a very
well-known author and critic.
A woman. I can't remember
her name for the moment.
Anyway, she gave it a terrible
review in "The New York Times,"
and then about six weeks later,
she wrote another review
and took back what she had said
the first time
because she understood
the show better.
-That's really amazing.
That doesn't happen.
How many times have you had
a critic change their mind
in your 100 years?
-That was it.
-That was it, yeah.
-My soon-to-be 100 years.
I'm only working on 100.
-Did you --
I've heard
you describe yourself as --
I've always thought of myself
as a writer
who works well under deadlines
because, you know,
I think like a lot of writers,
I procrastinate.
But I've heard you
call yourself --
I like this term a lot more
than "procrastinator."
You're a "clutch writer."
Is that what I think it means?
-[ Laughs ]
Well, I spent the --
many years
at the beginning of my career.
I had to deliver,
let's say on a Monday morning,
a monologue
for Tennessee Ernie Ford
or George Gobel,
and I'd start on it
the Wednesday preceding.
I'd be caught in a clutch.
[ Laughs ]
Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday, Saturday,
and sometimes Sunday.
Many times late at night.
Writing all night.
And finishing
what I was responsible for
five days earlier.
And without any sleep,
going down to Hollywood
to a reading
of what I had just written.
It was scary as hell,
uh, but we got through it.
-You received viewer mail
over the years, as well.
Not just about "All in the
Family," but all of your shows.
Was there a piece of viewer mail
you remember with any fondness?
-Uh...
I remember a piece of mail
where it called me
the number-one enemy
of the American family
in our generation.
And I didn't know his name
at first,
and then later I learned --
Wait a minute.
The guy who wrote it
is on the air,
and he's a reverend.
It's Jerry Falwell.
[ Laughter ]
Called me the number-one enemy
of the American family.
And then I heard
from Pat Robertson,
who certified
that Falwell was correct.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if it was just
one of them who said it,
I would take your side,
but if it was both of them...
[ Laughter ]
You --
I guess at a young age --
Someone who chooses his career
and sticks with it for so long,
at a young age,
you must have known
you had not just a good
sense of humor,
but maybe the ability to see
humor where others weren't.
Was that the case?
-You know,
when I was 9 years old,
my father got into trouble
and was sent to prison.
Something to do with fraud.
And the night he was --
Two nights
after he was called away,
my mother had to give up
the apartment we were living in
and so forth.
She was selling the furniture.
I was going off to live
with my grandparents.
Anyway, there were strangers
in the house looking at --
The thing that killed me most
was my father's
red leather chair
where we used to sit together
to listen --
I had radio.
No television then.
To listen to the fights
on Friday night
from Madison Square Garden.
Very sentimental to me.
And I was in --
not in good shape.
When a stranger who was
looking at my father's chair,
you know, about to purchase it.
Put his hand -- [ Laughs ]
Put his hand on my shoulder
and said,
"Well, Norman, you're
the man of the house now."
And somehow,
at 9 years of age,
I knew that was hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
I wanted to say
"[bleep] hilarious,"
but I don't know
whether I can do that or not.
-Well, Norman,
it was an honor
to speak with you,
but even more important
than that,
it was an absolute delight.
Thank you for making time
for us tonight.
-I couldn't have
enjoyed it more,
and I think the world of you,
Seth Meyers.
-[ Audience awws ]
-Thank you, Norman Lear.
"All in the Family: The Show
That Changed Television"
is out November 2nd.